Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar.
Consider the points (1, 1) and (2, 2). They can be connected
by the straight line y = x.
Similarly consider the points (1, 1) and (2, 7).
They can be connected by the parabola
y = 2x² - 1. These are
examples of connecting points with the
polynomial that has integer coefficients.
Now consider the points (1, 3) and (3, 2).
Can you connect these points by a polynomial
that has integer coefficients? That is,
can you find an equation of the
following form that passes through the
two points where all of the coefficients
are integers meaning they are positive
or negative whole numbers? If you can,
find an equation that passes through
these two points; if you cannot, prove why
it's impossible to do so. Can you figure
it out? Give this problem a try, and when
you're ready, keep watching the video for
the solution.
So it would seem you should be able to
find a polynomial that passes through
these two points because you're not
restricted to the degree of the
polynomial. However that turns out to be
not the case. It is actually impossible
to find a polynomial with integer
coefficients that passes through these
two points. We can, in fact, prove this by
contradiction. So, let's suppose we have a
solution. Because this solution passes
through the point (1, 3), that means
we can substitute y = 3
and x = 1. Since 1 raised to any power is
equal to 1, this simplifies to be 3 is
equal to the sum of the coefficients and
we know that each coefficient is an
integer. So, what we've proven is that the
sum of these integer coefficients is 3,
which is an odd number. We also know the
solution would have to pass through the
point (3, 2), so we can substitute
y = 2 and x = 3. Now we have to
simplify this a little bit. Consider the
powers of three. Since three is an odd
number, and an odd number times an odd
number is equal to another odd number, we
can conclude that all powers of three
are odd numbers so that means three to
the power of 'k' is always an odd number.
Furthermore, if the coefficient in a
particular power is even, then that
coefficient times 3 to the power of k
will be an even number. This is because
an even number times any number will be
an even number. If, on the other hand, the
coefficient is odd, then the coefficient
multiplied by 3 to some power will also
be an odd number, because an odd number
times another odd number is an odd number.
So we can conclude that 2 has the same
evenness or oddness as the sum of the
coefficients. We can write this in
another form. We can say that 2 is
congruent to the sum of the coefficients
when considering modulo 2. And this
implies that the sum of the coefficients
would have to be an even number.
So on the one hand we have the sum of the
coefficients being an even number,
and on the other hand we have the sum of the
coefficients being an odd number. This is
impossible; this is a contradiction to
say that some of the coefficients are
both even and odd at the same time
therefore our assumption that we did
find a solution is not correct, and thus
there is no such polynomial that can
pass through these two points with
integer coefficients. Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video.
Please subscribe to my channel. I make
videos on math and game theory. You can
catch me on my blog "Mind Your Decisions"
which you can follow on Facebook, Google+,
and Patreon. You can catch me on social
media at PreshTalwalkar, and if you like
this video please check out my books;
there are links in the video description.